stay-at-home orders may be temporary but
the pandemic could have lasting effects
of a generation on a generation rather
of children all around the country
they've had to adapt very quickly to
online learning digital playdates as
well as the isolation and certainly the
uncertainty that surrounds their
families at this time so with the help
of their parents we have we asked
several kids to keep video diaries of
their experiences so our filmmakers our
five-year-old CJ he lives in Illinois
seven-year-old Lily she's from Kentucky
eight-year-old Stella comes to us from
Texas and last but certainly not least
eleven-year-old Joaquin is in California
the corona virus is just a really bad
virus and it goes straight to your lungs
the journals like have a great thing in
the middle and they don't like red
things sticking out so it can stick to
stuff the virus one of the most deadly
[Music]
powers and some of the words that I have
or like hopeful determinist
just made when I do this rainbow to let
people get better lather stick I just
had all these paints and rocks all over
the place people find them it's really
fun my mom and dad are working and their
teachers so when they are working and
they don't have time to play with me I
follow this schedule that my mom made to
keep me busy during the day this point
is doing wonders
at home school it's really different
from my real school because you get your
mom or something is your teacher trying
to do math here just trying to do some
mad
[Music]
[Music]
me and my grandma we planted that one
tree but though she's not here with us
because of quarantine I have to take
care of it
we put truffles and run over there and
dresses because I want to play dress up
and have no one to play dress up with
Barbies don't have to social distance
because they're just Barbies one thing I
worry about quran virus is that I might
not get get to see my friends again a
long time I'm worried about that I
making sure that my friends don't get
the cars it's Saturday and usually on
Saturdays we volunteer for a animal
rescue and that's how we got our dogs hi
Levi so I'm really disappointed that we
can't go because of social distancing my
mom dad think it's not surprising
me and my brother just goes on the field
by myself we doing my stay in shape and
we stay healthy
I'm going for a walk with my mom dad and
my dogs it's a good place for getting
your energy out or just peacefully walk
what do we like to do why are we doing
that they announce that there is going
to be no school for the rest of the year
so how to do home school until
coronavirus and I'm really sad about it
am I gonna have to home-school for third
grade what's gonna happen next but I
just don't wanna stay a home for so long
because I just wanna go to my friend's
house is so bad I had to do her all by
myself it's so fun but it's not as I
used to do what do you hope for in the
future
a pandemic like this never happens and
when this ends everyone's nice to each
other
I really hope her virus and I get to see
my friends again
hmm ah children always put it in
perspective Tony I love that the kids
number one their perspectives the
innocence of children and I love hearing
their little voices the one little girl
that said what's going to happen next
that's a question we're all asking and
the poor dogs in the shot are like why
you got to put me in these clothes I
love that please special shout out to
Molly Missoula who put that together cuz
those things are hard to do you go Molly
great job Tony yeah yeah definitely yeah
they're very hard to do you know I found
myself wondering what are those kids
gonna grow up and be you know how is
this in affecting their their hopes and
dreams a little CJ there at the
beginning was describing what the
coronavirus looked like Anthony maybe a
future doctor maybe a future
epidemiologist maybe he'll stop the next
pandemic when he grows up that's right
I'm with Gail I love the faces on the
dogs who did that clearly did not like
playing doggy dress-up but they also
loved the Barbies Barbies don't have to
social distance that's the good news